in this shot from 1950s destination moon
these stars were actually 2 000 light
bulbs from
car headlights it was probably the most
realistic portrayal of space at the time
but 68 years and several real-life space
missions later
first man used state-of-the-art led
screens to project realistic renders of
the solar system
and the moon's surface even adding a
reflection on ryan gosling's helmet
it took decades of technical
breakthroughs to get to this point
from intricate wire work and robotic
cameras to
cg legs floating in zero gravity
here's how space scenes have transformed
over 120 years
long before humankind took their first
steps on the moon
filmmakers sought to bring their stories
to space
in 1902's a trip to the moon director
georges melies created the illusion of a
capsule landing in the moon
using a substitution splice first
shooting the actor playing the moon
then adding the capsule in another shot
and combining the two frames
while this iconic shot is obviously
fantastical
destination moon wanted to be as
scientifically accurate as possible
however the filmmakers had both a
limited scientific understanding of
space
and a limited toolbox for special
effects
in addition to using light bulbs for the
stars in deep space
the cast also used a matte painting as a
backdrop
with small cracks to create the illusion
of perspective on the moon
but the biggest innovation at the time
wires
to create the illusion of low gravity
director irving pitchell attached the
actors to piano wire run through a
pulley system and controlled by an
overhead crane this effectively lifted
the actors off the ground
but keeping the wires from showing up on
camera was a lot of work
according to writer robert heinlein the
set lights could make the wires visible
on camera during filming
if the wires were seen in the take
they'd have to start all over again
the movie also wanted to show characters
moving as the ship
left earth's orbit to create the
illusion of a person walking around
all sides of the ship the crew built the
set with a fixed camera and two gimbals
that way the camera could rotate in sync
with the set
it was similar to the rig that allowed
fred astaire to famously dance on walls
in 1951's royal wedding
all of these innovations took a lot of
time and money
as heinlein wrote realism is
confoundedly expensive
perhaps for that reason space scenes
throughout the 1950s and 1960s
frequently relied on the audience's
suspension of disbelief
take this shot of a flying saucer in
plan 9 from outer space
it's clearly just a toy on a string but
that would all change
drastically in 1968 with 2001
a space odyssey now that humans had
actually gone to space
stanley kubrick needed to redefine what
futuristic life in space would look like
and he did so by pushing the limits of
visual effects
when it came to wires kubrick found that
by simply placing the camera on the
ground
the actor's bodies would naturally block
the wires from view
but the zero-g illusions got much more
elaborate
the team built a 38-foot tall centrifuge
that rotated at
three miles per hour to imitate
artificial gravity
unlike the rotating set in destination
moon this one had two cameras
a mounted one that moved along with the
set and a dolly camera that moved with
the actors
but not all the sets were gigantic these
models were much more detailed elaborate
and closer to real nasa spacecraft at
the time
thanks to kubrick's famously obsessive
attention to detail
to make the miniatures look like they
were moving the camera was driven along
a track on a motorized mount around the
models
this method made it possible to exactly
repeat camera moves
the crew would do one pass of the
discovery another pass of the stars and
then combine it all into one seamless
shot
kubrick basically created an early form
of motion control cameras
and these new cameras revolutionized the
space saga
with star wars with a new hope george
lucas wanted to create
awe-inspiring space chases and battles
and audiences could be right in the
action thanks in part to a man named
john dykstra and his new camera called
the dykstra flats
the dijkstraflex was programmed by a
computer to move around the miniatures
in such a way to create the illusion of
speeding through space like this
imposing angle of the underbelly of a
star destroyer
or this shot during the death star
dogfight that appears to be from a
pilot's point of view
the camera's precise programming also
made shots easily repeatable for
seamless compositing
it's why multiple models could be shot
separately and then combined during the
dog fight
it's also why the death star really
looks like it's floating up in space
when in reality this close-up was shot
in a parking lot
motion control cameras can be seen again
and again in space movies
they were used in the star wars sequels
throughout the 1980s and
all the way through 2014 for the
practical models of interstellar
but all of these movies were about
fictional space travel
things needed to be a lot more realistic
with apollo 13.
houston we have a problem oh boy what's
going on here flight let me get back to
you
so director ron howard put the cast in
actual zero g for wider shots
it was the first movie ever shot on
nasa's kc-135
where real astronauts trained for space
conditions at the time
the plane flies up 35 000 feet in the
air before
plunging back to earth this renders all
passengers weightless for 25 seconds
no wires needed the crew only had 25
seconds per ride to shoot so the
filmmakers broke down each scene into
small chunks
and then later used wires on set for
close-ups
in total the cast and crew took 612
flights
adding up to nearly four hours of
weightlessness
shooting on the vomit comet looks
authentic but the limited zero g windows
make it a logistical nightmare
and what do you do for shots that need
to be much longer
gravity contained harrowing continuous
takes in space that lasted as long as
15 minutes making it difficult to both
move
and light the actors properly we went to
incredible lengths on
on the movie gravity to portray
microgravity or zero gravity
first the crew relied on pre-visualized
animations that showed what the movie
would look like before
shooting took place studying hours of
reference footage to create the digital
characters also helped them
imitate weightlessness more accurately
people do not move
slowly as though they're under water in
space that's a common
misconception if you watch those
astronauts they move really quickly
because there's no air resistance
to tackle the sequence where a debris
storm hits the characters
director alfonso cuaron and
cinematographer emmanuel lubezki
invented a new technology called a light
box
we were going to run for 15 minutes
without a hard cut
we had to be able to plan the lighting
and have perfect continuity because
everything was going to need to sit
together
the light box built on existing
technology sandra bullock and george
clooney were strapped into tilt rigs
while their space journey was captured
by motion control cameras
all of that was inside a box covered
with led panels that could for example
show
real images of earth from space as the
backdrop
because it was all programmed they could
change up the lighting faster than any
normal studio light
which came in handy for the scene where
they're hit by space debris
movies like first man built on the light
box and went even further with
led screens director damien chazelle
used a 35 foot tall 65 foot wide
led screen to provide dynamic 180 degree
views of space in
real time that meant the gemini space
capsule leaving earth could be captured
in camera
and because this life-size model was
motorized the camera didn't need to fake
any movements
you could even get this convincing lunar
reflection on ryan gosling's helmet
making the moon realistic took a lot of
effort as well
neil armstrong's moonwalk was shot in a
quarry at night that was manicured with
gravel to replicate the moon's surface
later that footage was combined with
real surface scans of the moon provided
by nasa
it's the tiny details like this that
really sold first man
look at this shot the extra dust that
clouds each footstep
was added entirely with cg and cgi might
be the answer when it comes to truly
mimicking zero g
movement gravity is impossible to get
away from you just you're constantly
under it
frame store made great strides in
digital doubles in the midnight sky
making weightlessness look more real
than ever before you hold your limb out
and swing around you can't feel gravity
doing its thing we were able to
completely eliminate that
digital doubles allowed filmmakers to
conquer more challenging weightless
scenes
like these wide shots of crew outside
the aether
this actor was minimally wired up on set
but his legs were swapped out with a
digital pair so there was no hint of
real-world gravity
fewer wires meant they didn't have to
worry about where the camera was placed
as they did in space odyssey
the team also used a virtual camera
system where the cinematographer
referenced an ipad showing rough
animated footage
by pointing it around an empty room he
could physically block out the shots
this level of planning allowed the
spacewalk to feature 70 fully
cg performances the technology has come
so far in the 10 years since we did
gravity that you can do these things in
quite a lightweight way and it is
interactive and easy enough for a
director to just hold an ipad and look
around a set
the result is a series of shots where
digital movements wire stunts and even
hidden crew members lifting objects into
the air
all contribute to make space travel both
terrifying and
awe-inspiring so we've come a long way
since apollo 13 and indeed we've come a
long way since gravity
melies made a capsule fly so kubrick
could defy the laws of gravity
so cuaron could capture the light of the
solar system
each might seem like a small step on its
own
but taken all together it was one giant
leap for cinema
one dust cloud at a time
[Music]
you